and dango wow i just love all the parts  of that order love the fan i love the  dang i love the go go go feels like one  of those fun group words like a congress  of owls with a fandango of feathered  hats i could do this all day i mean it's  an incredible word anyway my movie  marcel the show shoes on is out now and  tickets are available right here on  fandango  fandango of helens on a cruise and  learning  you know there's nothing in here about  finding them  there's so much nothing  she's the best she  what but my dad has pink shoes sort of  my grandfather  so cute  peace uh yeah obviously peace  like  what a weird thing to try to test to see  if someone else is into like of course  i'm into peace  no sorry i'm a real war person  no war actually i signed all my personal  letters war  let the battle begin marcel  [Music]  you